[Music]
alan is in ogden utah hey alan how are
you
i'm pretty good i'm having trouble
hearing you try again
uh so my fiance
is having trouble getting on board with
you the idea of following the baby steps
and living the day's life
i've been listening to you guys for
probably about two years now and i'm for
the idea but it's really hard to get
going on it if you don't have a partner
who's on board with you
help me help her understand what you're
trying to sell
[Music]
okay what is her problem with this idea
well she heard a one podcast
you guys did where this guy had a that
you sold him
to sell it and buy something else
because it was it was sinking him and i
personally i saw the logic and what you
said
but what she didn't understand is why he
told him to ramp it up to 9 000
rather than keep it down at the like
three or five thousand dollars that he
was going to spend
that's not her problem and that's what i
tried to tell her
no that's not what she heard on a
podcast is not the problem
she was looking for an excuse to not do
this stuff when she's listening to the
podcast
so she found some little nuanced nothing
detail that doesn't even matter
to to have a reason to throw that's
right that was the idea of evidence that
dave is cuckoo so we can't do this
and that's there's plenty of evidence
that davis cuckoo it's fairly
fairly abundant not hard to find that if
you're looking for we provide it daily
yes we do it's here it's
15 000 hours of it in the last few years
but um
it's all on youtube by the way yeah but
yeah so
you know there's a lot of reasons to but
you know and it's not a matter of
me as you know it's not it's not a
personal thing
in the sense of oh she doesn't like me
that's not the issue the the question
is that you guys have got the two of you
got to sit down and say okay
what are our goals
with money as a couple and what is the
best
method to get us to those goals
you see and i i love her to death but i
keep living in debt and i can't keep
living paycheck to paycheck that wasn't
what i said
that wasn't what i said you're not
living in debt anyway because you're not
married it's her problem if you leave
her with it
uh if you get married now it's your
problem so
as a precursor to getting married the
two of you
need to set a date after you've gotten
some good pre-marriage counseling which
it sounds like you desperately need
and um and after you've sat down and
said
where okay how old are you guys
we are 30 and 31 okay when you say when
we're 50
5 years old where do we want to be with
our money
and what is the best method to get there
and you both then answer that question
and you say
hey i'd like to be out of debt and be
very wealthy
and be able to be very generous and be
able to travel
and be able to buy something and not
have to worry about it and this is what
you would say
right and then she can say whatever she
wants to say
and you say okay what is the best way to
get to
this dream and let's make sure our
dreams are combined
before we combine our lives
yep alan i'm going to weigh in here i
want to go a little deeper
do you both have debt individually
yes she has about twelve thousand
dollars worth of
medical debt and i have about a thousand
dollars
worth of consumer debt okay well you're
a
on a budget of about 20 000
a year okay but listen here's the thing
if if when you sit down with a marriage
counselor
in pre-marriage counseling and you say
what do you want to be
when we're 55 and she says oh i don't
know i just don't want anybody telling
me what to do
dude you're not marrying a woman you're
marrying a princess and you need to run
yeah that's what i'm getting at alan i
want to know why she's resisting
you need to know what her resistance is
to dave's thing and you can have it in
the same conversation and then i'd want
to know the why before you put
before you go down the aisle because
there is a there's something that she's
resisting
um in what you're telling her and you're
telling her how we teach
yeah and and it gets you where i would
assume
she would agree with the vision uh that
that you would want and so
this is so serious alan that i mean to
me
i i'd press pause on the engagement i'd
press pause on everything until you guys
got on the same page about well
you do it no i wouldn't do that i would
just get with a marriage counselor a
pre-marriage counselor immediately and
you guys begin to talk
okay but what happens if that may lead
you to pressure that's what i'm saying
you need to but i don't want to just
break them up no i don't mean that
you know i think you need to go and i
don't mean that sit down there
and um uh
you know sit down and try to work that
through um
and you know let's figure out what we're
doing but
if at the end of the day i have been in
situations when i'm coaching couples
and one or the other of them uh
is like pounding their fists demanding
that
no limitations be put on them in any way
and that they're allowed to do whatever
they want to do and they they don't have
they're not accountable for the future
they're not accountable to themselves
much less their future spouse about
how we're going to end up then what
you've got there is someone throwing a
temper fit you got a four-year-old
throwing a temper fit on the cereal
aisle because they can't get cheerios
and that this is not marriage material
no
and so that you know uh uh the old
joke is if a guy marries a girl who
loves spending money you better enjoy
making money but that's not true it
doesn't work that
doesn't you can't make enough to you
can't out earn
somebody who's a super spender yeah
you're playing them before there were
super
spreaders they were super spenders so
yeah right uh but yeah
and i don't think this is what's going
on with her i think there's something
else i really don't think she's a bad
egg i don't either that's why i want to
know
what's the resistance and why i want to
know the why and it could be
too much information it could be too
that you have used me as a weapon on her
uh-oh and turned me into a cuss word and
you've jammed up you've stopped up this
conversation
and constipated it and so you're gonna
have
you may have to just back away from the
dave thing because dave's not relevant
in this discussion
the two of you being on the same page
about a method of some kind
to get to where you want to be and being
on the same page on where you want to be
now that's vital huge i'm just going to
say it dave i mean you can correct me if
you think it's too strong
i'm just coming from the position of
watching couples
and and if you aren't on the same page
about money you're playing the marriage
lottery
oh and you're playing russian roulette
and the odds are so against you
number one cause of divorce of course
and it's money fight some money problems
so if you can't get on the same page
without money ahead of marriage don't
get married yeah
i know i don't think that's too strong
okay but i mean the number one people
die
of a bear attack is walking down the
street don't walk down that street
you know i mean it's it's really common
sense you know good point so
um you know bears are on that street
they will kill your butt you know i mean
it's just like
so yeah this is not hard yeah and so
um yeah stay you know
stay off of that and um you know i saw a
statistic the other day
that uh uh like 37 of the current
divorces also mentioned
a a spouse looking up an old boyfriend
or girlfriend on facebook oh boy
so the second leading cause of divorce
is facebook right
yeah so i'm good with getting rid of
that too yeah you should
yeah what could have been what are you
doing what are you doing
what are you doing going back i mean
come on now
yeah you just want to be satisfied
that's all
then you just go they didn't look at
that that's another problem he lost all
his hair look at that
right so yeah exactly but uh anyway
yeah so tr the all kidding aside alan
it's it's imperative
if you were my son or daughter i would
tell you it's imperative
to be on the same page on religion
money in-laws and kids yes
with the help of a pre-marriage
counselor before you get married there's
all kinds of data and research that
shows those four things
are your leading indicators to a
fabulous
fabulous marriage one other little
nugget dave because i can't help it
alan if you do premarital counseling she
won't give in don't you give
in don't you do money the way you don't
want to do it
just to try to make her happy that ain't
gonna work either don't capitulate
yeah yeah we gotta come to agreement
yeah
not a concession that's what i wanted to
point out